This isn't like confidential stuff,
but you sitting on a porch looking over the world,
looking at the work that Andre is doing any laws during the Tesla autopilot. Uh,
do you like the trajectory of where things are going on?
They're making serious progress.
I like the videos of people driving the beta stuff.
Like it's taken some pretty complicated intersections and all that, but it's,
it's still an intervention for drive. I mean,
I have Autopark the current autopilot, my, my Tesla, I use it every day.
Do you have full self driving beta or no? No. See you like where this is going.
We're making progress. It's taken longer than anybody thought. You know, my,
my wonder was is, you know, hardware three,
is it enough computing off by two, off by five by 10 off by a hundred.
Yeah. And I thought it probably wasn't enough,
but they're doing pretty well with it now.
And one thing is the dataset gets bigger. The training gets better.
And then there's this interesting thing is you sort of train and build an
arbitrary. So he's not worked at solves the problem.
And then you refactor the network down to the thing that you can afford to ship.
Right? So the,
the goal isn't to build a network that fits in the phone it's to build
something that actually works. And then,
then how do you make that most effective on the hardware you have?
And they seem to be doing that much better than a couple of years ago.